[Music]
today we are going to talk about room so
we ask people to write offline ready
applications throughout your application
to work without a network connection but
if you don't have a proper model inside
your application it's pretty much
impossible to write a good offline
explains so for that reason you do need
a database luckily on Android we have
SQLite and SQLite is a really really
awesome technology it's very fast and
when you need to optimize it for your
use case it's very easy to do so it's a
very powerful query language you can
express many different things and make
it concise and easily grab the data is
the biggest advantage compared to other
object stores or key value stores and
SQLite also skills very well I mean for
an application you probably won't have
much data but you can have multiple
gigabytes of data and SQLite will be
just fine and as company is using it on
the back end so for your like scalable
to data size these SQLite will be
perfect
now SQLite on Android was not that cool
you need to write out of boilerplate
code to convert between your Java code
line objects on your SQLite there is no
compile time safety so if you are
building in SQL query and you forget
like a one comma if case you're going to
get a runtime crash and it's very hard
to test all those cases you can also
cannot observe what has change that we
want people to write reactive
applications or react to us and if you
cannot observe your data model it's kind
of hard you have to build it yourself so
we build it for you so a two years ago
we ship room we introduced the compile
time safety we introduced observable T
and we introduced the strong IDE
integration as you can notice with like
we drew with navigation this is a big
team for us we want to develop libraries
together with Android studio to provide
a nice user experience then this year's
i/o we introduced writer logging which
subida SQLite
and we also introduced support for
Beijing so that you can have very large
data sets queries and you can easily
load them in Terry cycler wheel 2.0
release is just our conversion from
Android support to Android X and we kept
it the same as one point one so that you
can have an easy migration and two point
one is what we are going to talk about
today and this is actually kind of the
Excel 2.0 it's a very large release we
have like full-text search we use multi
instance foundation auto valium or rx
stuff so let's talk about them
Suite one of the pretty cool new
features we are in 2.1 it's full text
search or FPS and FPS is basically a way
to index text document and make them
searchable it's a little let's take a
look at an example imagine we have a
music app and we want a search
functionality to it you know you have a
search box you want to type something
and you want to be able to find songs
within the music app if we have room you
know we express we store this song data
in a table that's an entity conveniently
we have or label as an embedded updates
and or some labels you know what's the
sound name the album name an artist name
this is kind of like what we want to
search and make the index if we were to
do this with our ftes right now you know
we need to write a query and basically
you have to use the like operator this
is not very good it's very limited that
percentage sign it's kind of like a wild
card and this basically causes a full
table scan yeah like even a few index
that query column in the database
SQLite will not be able to use that
index because the index only works if
you are doing a prefix search which is
not what you want to do here yeah so
don't do this moreover if you try to
actually search across almond or an
artist you have to expand this query and
this as you can see doesn't doesn't
easily scale FTEs help us with this
because it create it now creates a
virtual table and all the other columns
are indexed and to use FTS you just now
annotate your entity with FTS now in the
query instead of using like you would
use match which is a different operator
and as you can see here we use square
spawn so we're using the same table name
as our column in our were statement and
that basically tells the match operation
that you want to search across all those
labels so this helped us with searching
across our Tunes an album if you have an
omnibus you might say oh then I can use
FDS on all of my tables if I have an
extreme but not quite so using FTS
consumes more disk space and the reason
is because when you create an SDS table
you actually create a retool table and
that's back by a few tables where your
content is and a lot of the indexing
information this is known as chatter
tables when you actually query from your
Beatle table the information actually
comes from these tables there's also a
few drawbacks also to FTS you cannot
have foreign keys on your entity or come
or compose primary keys but there's one
pretty neat feature which is external
content and let's go back to our song
entity if we wanted to instead use our
real table and create a second table for
only our labels we just basically use
that fds annotation but we tell it hey
my data is actually gonna be storing
this other real table that I already had
conveniently this new data class and the
virtual table only has the labels so in
a previous example
everything was indexed so even the URL
which is not quite what we wanted to
index in this case we only have the
labels
what happens now says we have a virtual
table in front of it asana TS and behind
it it has the same shadow tables for
anything but the actual content is
stored in the original some table that
we had this is way better in saving this
space and it's a little bit more
flexible to query this external content
place FTS table with external content
you do have to query from the virtual
table and then you would do a join
because we want to get the songs and
then similarly you will still use match
one thing though is that because these
are two different tables when you insert
into the sound tables things are not
actually inserted into the virtual table
at the s table which means your in this
is doesn't get updated so you have to do
that yourself
but you know we don't want you doing
this we make an ax we want to make it
easy so when you use wroom wroom will
actually create triggers for you to keep
these two things in sync that's pretty
cool right another important feature we
have added is support for database views
so let's go back to our song and album
example we have songs and they have
albums and a song might be multiple
albums so we have a junction table that
Association associate the songs with the
audience now this so cool so let's say
you want to fetch a listing right you
want to have the ugly name and all the
songs in it as a list okay cool we just
right there we have the listing cost and
we write a query and fetch from that
junction table unfortunately you cannot
do this because that table doesn't have
the song's name or the album's title you
kind of need to write a query like this
where you fetch from that table and join
it with the song and album table and
then you can return your listing data
now the section cool SQLite is powerful
that you can express this but if you
find yourself keep writing these things
it's kind of like a lot of boilerplate
like things you need to keep in your
mind wouldn't be cool if you could just
have a table that has the song and the
album together without you duplicating
the data into that table and the songs
and the album tables and this is where
database views come into place so you
basically write the query that defines
album and song together as a query you
annotate an entity with a database view
so you're saying that the second wheel
to this database and in that poor joe
this is the
room rules so you can have any power
over the embedded fields or whatnot
once you declare it and edit your room
database so we have that declaration if
you try to rewrite the previous query
you just get rid of all the joint and
instead select from that tables well we
are selected from a view that table
doesn't exist but for all intensive
purposes of querying that's a table and
now it's much much more simpler because
I say it's like a table you can also
return that POJO or you can even return
a live data because we know how that we
was constructed we know when the value
might change so you can get a live data
of it you can run queries like you could
pretty much do everything you can do
with a table except you cannot do
inserts and updates because there's no
baking data but you can have wheels
inside other wheels like all that stuff
works so this makes it much nicer to
write queries and it also allows you to
logically address your data another
important feature we have added is
support for multiple instances so let's
say we are writing the application so we
have a playlist all the songs and we
have a sync service that ghost our
back-end pulls the name updates for my
playlist and writes them into a database
when you're using room if the sync
service updates the database it
automatically updates the UI and this is
a super cool feature because you write
these two components absolutely
independent of each other they don't
know about each other they have the
database as a sync point this works
perfectly but then your startup is
successful you grow your team your
application is bloated so you decide to
move that synchronization inter
background process now it's been is
running in a different process it pause
the song rises in the database and your
UI has no idea it doesn't know the
database has change because it only
knows that data is exchanged if the same
room instance is the one making the
update so we can fake it because we
don't get any information from SQLite
there's something room tracks
now with room 2.1 you can enable multi
system validation when you build the
room instance which were loop which will
look for other instances of room that
are accessing the same database once you
do that now your background process
service can update the database and all
this and soft room will update
automatically now we don't do this this
is off by default because we need to
create the service there's some IPC
involved is not a big cost but it is a
cost that most people don't need so you
need to enable this flag to take
advantage of this feature another
feature we added which was actually
requested by the community is out of a
new support you know if you're using
Kotlin you don't have to worry about
this because you have data classes but
if you're stealing java well then you
might want to have you might be using
autovalue because you want Java
immutable objects all room.now can
understand these auto value annotated
updates even if you know a little bit
about what value you basically have an
abstract class and you annotate it with
auto value but now you can also
undertake that same math class with
identity and room will be able to
discover that you want to make a banking
SQLite table for it another value
instead of having fields you have
astrogators these can now be annotated
with room annotations to declare primary
key column information and things like
that the only caveat though is that you
do have to also add other values copy
annotation and this is this is the
annotation that basically makes these
two tools work together why do we
support this so normally these
annotations were only limited to fields
and we needed extend it to let you put
them on those abstract methods but it
only works if you're using author well
if you're not using autovalue we are not
gonna let it compile yep
similarly if you were writing a normal
but a class you have a constructor with
the fields in not value oh you still
need that factory method and we'll we'll
be able to discover this to create your
other value class and then you see net
is you would use it as any other data
class you would use the abstract class
that you declare
another highly requested feature that
has been working for we decided that has
been requested for a while and we
finally got it is more rx so now you can
actually have a synchrotron x
completable single and maybe in metal
sanitary will insert update and delete
so you know we'll listen and you when
you request our you know we'll listen
yeah yeah this is actually yeah it's
only available in rx that's interesting
might be available another other type of
passing like qualities call this maybe
please so so route 2.1 is a really big
release like the full-text search the
database views i were me decided which
features to work on we are basically
relying on your feedback like these are
literally like I personally objected
that allowing complete of less stuff in
those like insert queries for a long
time and I gave up because people really
wanted it and this is our development
philosophy we basically look at what the
community is doing how are they using it
what do they want and implement them so
please like try to use 2.1 is a very big
release and we want to just like ship it
as stable as soon as possible and we
need your feedback we basically look at
the number of apps shipping meet room
and see how they are using we look for
the incoming box I mean we don't really
have bugs but sometimes nobody look for
incoming user errors try to fix them
and then we try to ship so please work
with us and we will try to wrap it up
and ship it and also please let us know
what other features you want in groov so
that we can implement them alright
thanks a lot for coming to this talk I
hope it was useful
[Applause]
[Music]
you